hey guys Ryan right here this is cat
daus guys no cat on sugary cats wearing
I wanna shoot me cats where this is we
can swear right now looks good anyway
everyone keeps talking about the ice
water challenge does that whether we
have a bucket and we're gonna do this on
the beach and we're smart and we really
care about this so we're going at like 6
o'clock when it's really [ __ ] cold
outside cuz we were gonna prove and
honestly I forgot what the whole cause
is about oh yeah but cat is more of a
personal thing for you isn't it well yes
we're using sustainable sea water
because right now California is in a
drought and we don't want our state to
dry up so we're going to just dump it
right on me and back into the ocean
exactly or on the beach
hey guys were at the beach and cat
forgot to bring us towels so we're about
the freezer asses off after this fun
little game we're about to do and I
really can't don't I wasn't even pay
attention with cats that I forgot what
the whole cosmos you can either donate
to the cause or dump ice on yourself I'm
actually gonna make a small donation as
well and and we're using sustainable
seawater so that we can also bring
awareness to the drop so if you want to
donate to saving water and giving water
to people that need it I think that's
okay too
alright yeah good causes still gonna pay
attention
whoa what happened there
okay I'll go with you for a little bit
yeah Bobby holy [ __ ] the water soaked
yeah get the dirtiest water you can [ __ ]
remember Lou Gehrig's disease you got
the most disgusting water you get honey
you're supposed to pour it on yourself
all right yeah
okay
are you it what you got yeah
we have nothing to rinse off on we
didn't bring towels were ever so I'd
like to nominate my roommate Brittany
bird Eli Staters
Niraj Vitya Tony lunge Pete
Jonathan Daniel brown
Steve Saunders summer
and James Hyatt are you guys up for the
challenge
I don't know any of these folks and I'd
like to nominate Ryan Wright and Ryan
Wright is about to take the ALS
challenge do I get a body shot of course
look at that sexy body right there
I'm kind of embarrassed he came here to
the beach that you're lucky to be
seeking this guy it's true you're like
do you think we want to go right to the
gym and workout for the rest of my life
they're hot girls on ready
and boom behind you what that was I feel
like I'd be a lot more passionate about
ridiculous
one two three oh yeah yeah not many
people I'm shaking the camera oh yeah I
nominate sherry no be nominated Sally I
nominee free nominate Veronica and I
nominate well I nominate Jesus Christ
our Lord and Savior why not yeah yeah
yeah cat it's [ __ ] cold why don't you
bring a goddamn cow there's sand in my
mouth
holy [ __ ] it is [ __ ] cold outside my
nipples are so hard right now and my
balls are freezing